[Music]
here's your little triangle that you
have okay
so as he goes whatever he's trapped
certain ways on that night okay so he
has to do other things instead of
stabbing me like what he's trying to do
okay
[Music]
stabilize the wrist
against the counter pull
grab from the triangle and then your arm
is right here
boom arm right there
so he can try to grab yeah grab
inside
okay
he goes home take stay on the knife
instead
have the knife he goes whatever okay
there it is right here
oh
and he's gonna grab something you see
he's trying to gank me
and now i gotta do it again okay
well let's just say he got there's no
knife he yanks me and i loose and
yield to it you understand okay so it's
kind of a
mind girl it's a mind girl so don't let
the knife capture you cause then you're
going to get stuck and now this is going
to caffeine okay
so i'm doing this he does his thing
that's how i move in
i'm not now making a technique out of it
you understand
i i wait
he does his thing and i move him
he does his thing i move it
don't re-grab and try to find songkill
you just work in the knife
next one
forget the knife he goes
ditch the
where he knife for oh when he goes for
it
again he goes forward
that's what he's doing
he goes
go with this energy
this is a knife
come on dude
[Music]
and now i'm not going to pull you
backwards your energy is going that way
so i'm not going to yawn you
okay
so we'll go slow just like
big
circle my body makes a big circle but my
hand does not make a big circle
my hand makes it smaller
you see that
no
there
okay
[Music]
he's getting the clinch and he's coming
more around you see
so i see that energy boom this one
okay so we'll just look at this anti
clench thing just take that out oh he
wants to bring he wants to anchor his
elbow and get that head neck control
so this is where i went to do it
you can't get it on that arm okay you
can use two arms
he's weak
he can't get it
okay
he's gonna have to do something else do
you understand
okay so
you gotta go without the energy of the
knife but you can't submit to the clinch
okay
so he feels the obstacles and he came
under it so i move out of the way i
don't like the knight
he goes under it i take this
high okay
i want you to watch
this spiral
spiral
not straight
boom
not moving
the fight is going to
turn
it's going to turn
okay
same thing goes in
here
angle on
okay
oh you're gonna try to get another grout
somehow i don't know what do you want to
do there we go
we go slow so you can see here i am
and then this elbow over your phone is
going to drop in
[Music]
right when you feel it come off okay
oh
[Music]
the heel hook to the drum okay
i'm stronger than you so i'm gonna win
you're good
[Music]
here's a go there's a place to fish
do you think
inside
this you see how i mean it just it goes
void right i'm not going to go here and
hold this and then just you pull my head
down i go like that
okay
i just change the angle
[Music]
and then this is
okay so when you come in
right to get it there you are
again you go i don't
try to get in there i just
on this other hand if you go inside this
hand boom
so
it looks like i'm looks like i'm doing
that but you can you can feel it
when you go
oh free space okay
got it
okay start out with the knife it's just
that it's easier i find as i've taught
over the years for people to understand
energy transference okay
uh as it's easier with the knife to
understand when you have better mind
okay but once you get
an unfettered mind it's easier to
understand energy transfers we're
now just doing energy transfer still
okay
so
when
he came here
but he also has that arm coming in he's
trying to get down all right he changed
so we're over here now okay
uh same thing i wouldn't come back here
now because he's pulling down on that
do you understand
so he's pulling down all that well
that's where i have to go
you guys get it okay so
last time we were here
then he's driving
well that's why he goes there
they're getting out of the way like
okay this time he came here and he's
trying to bring it down
okay so
same thing's gonna be he's gonna go and
crank down
so he's gone he's cranking down
right right when he takes me i don't let
i don't resist because he's gonna pull
me
so that's my energy and i'm gonna go
okay all right yes and i'm gonna go way
deeper
let's go into that
okay
okay so the first one is doing the
clutch and you had a wrist wrap you see
okay so with the wrist wrap and then
clinched you see i i have my cushions
and stuff do you understand okay so
on the first one foam
and then boom like he reached in with
that got it
so that's why i will where's the do you
see that push there
you understand
i'm not gonna go like
that's where i am okay
um and then what he did is he came up
you see
there's no penetration pay attention
there's no penetration okay
and that's what opened him up
to strikes
on the inside
he's not disturbing my balance you see
so
again he
i just want you to say it's not a matter
of understanding but
because you have to feel it but i want
you to know what you're trying to feel
okay
so he drove home then he came up there
was no push on my body so
i'll just hit on the inside because he's
just a bag to me now do you get it and
he's playing grappling game but doesn't
have control of my strikes okay
uh second one
he came here and he's trying to pull and
anchor me down you see that so again
energy is going there what i'm going to
do is go down but under him okay so he
goes and i go under him
let's do
[Music]
uh
a driving one so he did the first one
and now he drives in let's see
okay so let's see
if i can go under him when he's driving
me don't kill me okay
so he goes boom he's going under me i
can't get on i can't get unreal
not in that
shoulder
let's see if i strike at him when he's
driving happening
can't they're getting smothered
so same let's just look at
his energy he's driving it you see feel
that energy
we'll feel it
you'll always have richie
uchika
this time it's with your elbow
so we're here
he's driving
inside boom he drives home
[Music]
okay
try bro what what tends to happen uh
we're trying to do non-contestation do
you understand that okay but what tends
to happen is when we feel pressure we
push back on the person that and so even
if we see somebody
that we can feel is not pushing back on
the person
we interpret it as you're pushing back
on the person right you see you'd watch
the technique and you go bracing bracing
oh i understand bracing
do you understand but
then when you you feel it because it
doesn't look like it when you feel it
you're like okay that he wasn't bracing
i'm just grabbing air there's a place
where his power line is not working
that's in space that's where
non-contestation functions okay
so
here uh and we're going and he drives i
don't want to stop him i don't want to
say get ready get set go do you get that
and i don't want to go i'm not ready
okay but i and so i don't want to stay
here either and try to lift this arm
i'm inside and as i yield
it's getting softer
here's where he's strong
but as i yield it's getting softer
so i look for that softness and as i
yield
if for
example i want to do this spiral
you see
and you're like my head is he's still
got my head
don't start going
you just do the maneuver and lower your
head
you see how
because it's just not a contestation so
over here he drives
[Music]
your moose can get smaller because it
has more energy to transfer
okay
so it's not uncommon that the guy that
drives so he he's driving go ahead and
you drive
of you can't
do that i can't keep them open that's
not my heart okay so
be pushing and i go pull
a lot of times whoa and then turn around
[Music]
okay now he's looking at me in the back
okay
so first i want to show you the benefits
of starting the fights firing you always
have to start the fights firing so when
i go over here you see how we're turning
in space
can you see that
and
he's gonna drive but i'm gonna keep it
going and he'll come back at me
you see
you understand
but he's adding to this centrifugal
energy
so
one he goes and here he comes and you
gotta go you gotta come though because
you're trying to get me i'll do it
okay
so i'm pushing
right
and i'm driving
yeah i'm
dragging
okay so if we go slow
there okay
here
he drives he's driving i turn he drives
again
[Music]
okay
one more time
fries
okay let's try it
[Music]
and you're afraid you have to come in
okay
why do you have to come in
why do you have to come in on the second
attempt hurry up
why does dk have to come in on the
second attempt
are you going to answer me
that's the okay yes why does speaking
have to come in
on the second attempt they're attacking
okay they could have attacked any number
of ways they could have pulled down
they could have just stayed in place
why do they have to come in on the
second one on this last one
i'm going to help you because you are
going to answer me do you understand
okay
and i'm driving this time
you see
and he's gonna
do just pop and i'm gonna drive again
do you understand why did i drive that
last time
in this drill
he made more space no
you're training a technique
what technique did he throw with
hurry up you want to do it what's it
called
noggin
do you understand and cook it has a
fitting piece do you understand you
don't just do techniques wherever
got it so when they pulled me down i
went to katakuruma
do you understand
okay when he just held me in place well
i came to infighting they can't use
techniques every single place they don't
go every single place that's not
yin-yang
okay so you can reverse engineer if the
guy is doing cookie noggin
then the has to do what
he has to keep coming in so when you go
scaredy can't you get
and you're not coming in anymore
then he's not doing a technique that
makes sense
do you understand
so uke has to come in
just like we can have to pull down and
you're gonna have to stay still
because we're doing energy transfer so
you have to give the energy
so we transfer it
logically okay
you can't be afraid
you can't go slow
but you have to move in
got it
you saw what happened when he did not
get the spiraling geometry everything
looks straight
do you see that
because of what he did not do so for to
catch you back up
when i came here and he's trying to do
all these moves here i'm just going
straight
got it
it's me that makes it look like
he's missing
it's me that's making him when i'm
nugget
so when he comes in he has he has his
clinch he comes in and i'm here
i did that he he's not going on a circle
he's trying to come in straight
he's coming in home i go on a server
he's pushing in now again
you see
i can make him look straight by staying
straight
but he's coming in you're on the clinch
still
he's driving in and i turn do you see
and that's what makes him now turn he i
made him have to do that turn do you see
that
and then i do
this turn again
he's not doing those things i have to do
it
okay so he's in
one he drives
two
comes back three
one
two
three
now wash my hands
my hands are always in the perfect place
i can do cookie nuggets from here i
don't have to
change my hands
okay
he goes
he's gonna come i keep contact
good time
on i spiral the fight
two i turn five there it is
one
two
three
fitting
[Music]
okay
try it again